remember that woman who you thought got
you who you desired who did all that
wonderful soup that made you squeal in
bed remember her that woman
banished the second kids in the
depictive no I'll be fine as long as she
doesn't mention the minivan again you
should get a minivan Jason loves ours
don't you Jason can we just talk about
sports again I guess it could be worse
here's nothing she's asking for
vasectomy right there they are two of
them good to know
smooth smaller she would do it for Daisy
right if she asked Wow cutting me down
there not in a million years after all I
went through for you really your family
doctor sent over your blood tests and
they are normal for a man your agent
doesn't exercise congratulations you are
completely average candidate for a
vasectomy tell me and do not spare my
feelings what did I do to deserve this
she's attacking you on three fronts
minivan vasectomy and sex she's smart
man she's very smart I would love to see
one of you bleed out of your dates for a
week a month oh you know we haven't even
mentioned child okay Phil just take it
back right now we thought your boss what
you have to do is either work through
your fears and accept your Corinne sad
middle-aged married life or no I'm gonna
schedule your appointment for Monday
Monday yeah get the wipe off your back
you have a week to decide by the way
stock up the fridge with frozen peas
great for the Swan maybe we'll just
postpone the vasectomy maybe everything
can get back to normal around here I
don't think anything would be going back
to normal kids there's go to your room
you